but tonight we begin right here in
Vietnam tomorrow President Trump will
kick off a series of historic meetings
with North Korean dictator Kim jong-un
both leaders arrived yesterday president
Force on Air Force One and Kim jong-un
via a 60 hour train ride somebody buy
this guy a plane I guess maybe it was in
the shop getting repaired but two years
ago remember the hate Trump media Bob
told you we the people the president oh
he's leading us to nuclear annihilation
in response to what North Korea their
hostilities rockets being fly alone over
Japan threatening Guam threatening the
continental US Trump deployed multiple
aircraft carrier strike groups in the
region he'd nicknamed Kim jong-un a
little rocket man he reminded the despot
about America's nuclear superiority he
squeezed North Korea's only real ally
China with tariffs he deployed the
strategy called peace through strength
and all while America's left told you
the sky was falling he's going to start
a nuclear holocaust local rocket man
fire and fury my buttons bigger than
yours this is how the media reacted the
idea of a nuclear showdown with North
Korea keeps you up at night I would
recommend deleting your Twitter app he
is not merely being cavalier with a
threat about nuclear war he's being
cavalier in a way that it makes him seem
demented these are the messages from a
person who is not well from a leader who
is not fit for office
president Trump is goading Kim jong-un
to test a nuclear missile again to prove
its reliability to show him wrong and
fundamentally I think it comes across as
two kindergarteners who are jostling
each other except that each has nuclear
weapons too late after a hundred
thousand Americans die a nuclear
holocaust or after a million die inside
us where we are this is not an
exaggeration Trump's comments about
nuclear weapons have experts worried he
could literally inadvertently trigger a
catastrophe they said the same thing
when Reagan called the former Soviet
Union the evil empire and per usual and
he challenged Gorbachev tear down this
wall they're completely wrong
again and again and as you might have
noticed there's no nuclear holocaust in
fact quite the opposite what have we
seen North Korea completely stopping
firing ballistic missiles over Japan
threatening the region threatening Guam
threatening the continental United
States they return the remains of US
servicemen brave heroes have died in
battle during the Korean War they agreed
to negotiate the denuclearization of the
entire Korean Peninsula oh and hostages
will return a huge deal and it's not
just about North Korea now China is
being held accountable for its rampant
intellectual property theft and because
of the real serious threat of ongoing
terrorists well guess what new better
trade deals that help Americans that
help farmers that help manufacturers
that help our car industry are now on
the table despite all the success of
course the hate Trump media mob and
Democrats publicly rooting for the
president to fail in his upcoming
negotiations with Kim jong-un we have
eight US senators this is a joke
releasing an open letter the president
bashing him for his diplomatic efforts
insinuating our president is a liar well
let's look at the hate Trump media Bob's
obsession with a month's old statement
from the president oh that he and Kim
fell in love during their first
encounter okay let me translate this for
anyone in the media was too stupid to
figure it out on their own who never
left the comforts of their little TV
studios that are way overpaid the
president developed a beneficial working
relationship with someone we're trying
to negotiate with by the way if we can
stop North Korea from threatening the
entire region that would be a good thing
that's when nuclear annihilation is just
a button away if we don't fix it so
let's face it here's the sad reality we
have the left in this country Democrats
mainstream media they don't obviously
want the president to succeed not just
on this issue even when the safety and
security of the American people is on
the line this is sick they're psychotic
hatred of this president is more
important to them than the well-being of
South Koreans the entire region and
Americans
now if that wasn't the case remember it
would fund the wall in the southern
border like they were willing to do in
Obama's second term
what if Trump's doing it it's immoral if
that wasn't the case they could not have
tried to ruin Judge Cavanaugh's Life
smear slander besmirch ment during their
botched attempt to block his nomination
that wasn't the case they would not have
voted against the born alive bill which
would have protected living infants who
survived a botched abortion really
pretty heartless and all the Democratic
presidential candidates in the Senate
voted against this bill all of them now
that brings us to tonight's Hannity
history lesson while the left is
actively rooting against President Trump
because that then gets in the way of
their desire for power while their own
track record in foreign policy has been
an absolute disgrace frankly an utter
failure their failed strategy can be
summed up with two words international
bribery if only we suck up to dictators
and pay the money maybe they'll like us
1994 then President Bill Clinton
bragging about giving North Korea the
world in exchange for just a promise not
to build a nuke then the last long take
a look this is a good deal for the
United States North Korea will freeze
and then dismantle its nuclear program
South Korea and our other allies will be
better protected the entire world will
be safer as we slow the spread of
nuclear weapons South Korea with support
from Japan and other nations will bear
most of the cost of providing North
Korea with fuel to make up for the
nuclear energy it is losing and they
will pay for an alternative power system
for North Korea that will allow them to
produce electricity while making it much
harder for them to produce nuclear
weapons the United States and
international inspectors will carefully
monitor North Korea to make sure it
keeps its commitments only as it does so
will North Korea fully join the
community of nations well it wasn't a
good deal for the American people
because North Korea took the money and
ran and today yeah they have a nuclear
weapons arsenal President Trump
now stuck cleaning up his mess and sadly
Obama didn't learn from Clinton's abject
foreign policy failures number 2015 then
President Obama tried to bribe the
world's leading sponsor of terrorism
with a hundred and fifty billion dollars
in cash and other currency that they
dumped on a tarmac in Iran for the
mothers of Iran that's a death to
America and death to Israel and burn our
flags what do we get in return
we got a promise again that they
wouldn't develop nuclear weapons for a
few years President Obama called it an
unprecedented achievement in stupidity
but Iran used that money what we now
know to fund terrorism all over the
Middle East as proxies of wars all over
the place
killing so many innocent humans in the
process killing innocent civilians
around the world Iran still publicly
plotting the annihilation of Israel
still burning the US flag still chanting
death to America death to Israel and
Obama's flawed nuclear deal thankfully
because the president Trump is now
totally obsolete if we don't learn from
the past
yes we're doomed to repeat it just like
Reagan peace through strength we can
learn from success as well and that's
why the president will only up and open
up the spigot of economic opportunity in
North Korea
if Kim jong-un agrees to join the
nuclear non-proliferation treaty which
opens up his country to regular unabated
checks on his nuclear program and he'll
help his people out in the meantime and
he also has to agree to phase out and
dismantle all of his nuclear weapons
accountability verification or No Deal
now as a country that is learning from
our past failures is critically
important not just abroad but right here
in America within the United States our
country in 2010 when former President
Obama's fellow Democrats rammed
Obamacare down your throat remember they
made a lot of promises again and again
keep your doctor keep your plan and save
less and lower drug prices well a lot of
people lost their doctors lost their
plans and everybody's paying more all
Americans will be insured didn't happen
health care costs of skyrocket if some
Americans only have one play
twenty-seven million Americans today
still remain uninsured Bernie Sanders
Kamala Harris nearly every other far
left radical Democrat is pushing
Obamacare on steroids human growth
hormone times a million they're
literally calling for every American to
lose you cannot have private health
insurance and let our ever so competent
federal government the ones that gave us
Obamacare handle it all
take a look will these people be able to
keep their health insurance plans their
private plans through their employers if
there is a medicare-for-all program that
you endorse what they will what will
change in their plans is the color of
their cod so instead of having a Blue
Cross Blue Shield card instead of having
a United health insurance card they're
gonna have a Medicare card alright that
multitrillion-dollar big government
takeover just one small part of what is
now the radical extremist Democratic
Socialist 2020 agenda Kamala Harris
Elizabeth Warren pushing widespread
reparations also almost every single
Democratic candidate right now is
backing this insane green New Deal free
everything for everybody free child care
free housing free healthy food from
government healthy food free vacations
free Family Leave free health care but
you can't have a private insurer free
free free oh and retirement and you
don't even have to work oh yeah by the
way no more oil no more gas no more
airplanes no more cows no more powered
cars and the government will rebuild
every single building in America for
energy efficiency well all in ten years
and by the way we have our first cost
estimate at a meager low up to ninety
four trillion dollars even though the
world of course is supposed to end in
twelve years according to Acacio cortez
now this plan would wreck the united
states it would be an unmitigated
disaster nothing but a path to poverty
it would destroy the greatest wealth and
innovation producing system that mankind
has ever seen called capitalism and
that's not all the
radical plans keep coming and coming
it's open borders eliminate ice and if
they get their way
only the government gets to have the
second Amendment right in fact as we
speak House Democrats they are prepping
a bill that would criminalize many gun
sales and let's never forget their
unified opposition to living human
surviving abortions this is the new
extreme radical Democratic Socialist
Party all Democratic senators running
for president voted against the born
alive survivors Protection Act Wow the
most innocent among us our government
doesn't protect babies living on their
own what's the point
all of these radical plans they have one
common theme government power Democrats
want to bribe you we the American people
they want to take away all of your fear
convince you that giving up basic
fundamental rights in exchange for
security lofty government provinces pre
everything now it's time tonight we call
on everyone in America learn from
history bribery
dictators and kissing up to them never
works
socialism always ends in death poverty
and destruction for all we'll have a lot
more coming up in the course of the show
first let's preview what is about to go
down tomorrow in our nation swamp so
while the president is here in Vietnam
the president's former attorney Michael
Kohn is going to testify in public three
days in a row one two three okay
tomorrow is the only public one before
the House Oversight Committee he's going
to be grilled by some of the worst Trump
haters like Acacio Cortez congresswoman
Talib and others now keep in mind among
other issues Michael Kohn did plead
guilty lying to Congress wasn't long ago
the prominent Democrats hated Michael
Kohn called him out repeatedly for being
a liar now they're his best friend take
a look as far as Michael Cohen's
credibility Rudy Giuliani described him
as a proven liar I think that Michael
Cohen Rudy Giuliani and Donald
have about the same amount of
credibility they all use at best
situational ethics and but are probably
more likely they just lie constantly so
now Michael Cohen is the Democrats new
best friend forever sadly he's gonna
report to prison in May to serve a multi
year sentence he and you know what he
and his family have been through an
awful lot frankly hell and Democrats my
opinion are just shamefully using him as
a political prop not to learn anything
new but once again to bludgeon President
Trump to make it look bad while he's in
the middle of high-stakes historic
negotiations abroad here in Vietnam to
keep the world safer
whatever happened to politics ending at
the water's edge you know it is a pretty
heartless act by a group of people just
blinded by all things Trump and as a for
tomorrow as a kangaroo court plays out
on Capitol Hill President Trump is going
to be fighting for America's interest
abroad flying 25 hours to try and make
the world a safer place keepin the
country of the citizens of the United
States safe in the process pretty
despicable